para realizar en este vídeo es pensar un
poco en cómo es actualmente calculada la
tasa de desempleo por la oficina de
estadísticas laborales y bueno me
gustaría empezar con toda la población
de los estados unidos así que dibujando
aquí un gran círculo nos va a
representar dicha población la población
de los eeuu si no me equivoco los
últimos números o cifras que tengo
acerca de estos es que son 304 millones
de personas pero bueno estos trescientos
cuatro millones de personas no todos son
poblaciones económicamente activas
incluyendo no sé a mi hermana oa mis
pequeños sobrinos el porcentaje de esta
población que aún no está aquí la
podríamos llamar desempleo teóricamente
pero mejoraremos esencialmente con
adultos gente que ya está en edad de
trabajar así que son las personas que
tienen 16 años o más que son los que
laboralmente ya están legales entonces
la información que tengo es de
subconjunto de por aquí es que son
acerca de 237 millones de personas pero
bueno también hay que considerar que
toda esta gente está en posibilidad
claro de trabajar
pero hay algunos que están estudiando en
alguna universidad en algún colegio o
hay otros que incluso no tienen las
habilidades para trabajar por algún tipo
de enfermedad o algunos otros que están
retirados por lo que es necesario
realizar un subconjunto más que
esencialmente haga referencia a la
población económicamente activa da que
realmente está elaborando que están
activas trabajando o buscando trabajo
así que lo voy a dibujar exactamente por
aquí entonces este subconjunto lo voy a
denominar fuerza de trabajo no es gente
que está retirada ni gente que está
estudiando a esa gente la vamos a dejar
en el subconjunto de afuera siendo que
ellos tienen 16 años o más pero no
trabajan entonces a esto les vamos a
llamar gente que actualmente trabaja más
gente activamente buscando trabajo así
le llamamos gente activamente en busca
de trabajo porque también finalmente
generan a la población de fuerza de
trabajo y dicho número se iniciará son
correctas este es de 154 millones de
personas aunque los números son un
poquito importante es lo más importante
en este vídeo
tener la idea de cómo se calcula la tasa
de desempleo y ahora con todo esto la
fuerza de trabajo que tenemos en este
subconjunto como había dicho
anteriormente es gente trabajando pero
también gente que está en busca de dicho
trabajo así que este conjunto lo forma
porque es gente realmente interesada en
formar parte de la población
económicamente activa pero aquí lo
importante de dicho subconjunto es la
gente que está en busca de y no lo
consigue porque este pequeño subconjunto
de aquí que estoy poniendo de color
morado nos va a marcar lo que es
realmente el desempleo más la gente que
se encuentra activamente buscando uno
entonces buscando por aquí cifras será
la gente realmente desempleada que son
alrededor de 15 millones de personas
entonces si tú tienes trabajo te
encuentras por el círculo de afuera
donde puse el puntito y si tú no tienes
trabajo pero estás en busca de te
encontrarías dentro de este pequeño
círculo pero también deberíamos de
considerar a aquellas personas que no
tienen un trabajo pero tampoco están en
busca de alguno
los famosos ninis porque es población
que podría aportar algo económicamente
pero no se encuentran haciendo nada y es
interesante porque hace que la tendencia
de la tasa de desempleo tenga subidas y
bajadas constantemente y con dicha
información es con lo que calculamos la
tasa de desempleo pero bueno entonces la
tasa real de desempleo literalmente es
el número de desempleados que hay por
toda la fuerza laboral que sería la
cifra de los 15 millones de personas
entonces si queremos sacar el porcentaje
de estos 15 millones de personas se
tendrían que dividir entre los 154
millones de los que son población
económicamente activa entonces por aquí
en mi calculadora pondremos a este
ejemplo que la tasa de desempleo de los
15 millones está dividido por 154
millones entonces como podemos ver esto
nos arrojaría 19 puntos 74 por ciento
porque bueno esto sería si lo
multiplicamos por el 100 para creer el
porcentaje total entonces se recorrería
el punto decimal y sean los 9 puntos 74
por ciento ahora entonces los detalles
que dije que sean importantes y la razón
la cual esto se puede decir que es
relativamente grande es por las causas
que pasan cuando la gente está en
búsqueda del empleo o cuando empiezan a
buscarlo y no lo consiguen que es a lo
que llamamos realmente desempleo porque
como dijimos anteriormente por otro lado
si tú no tienes trabajo y no estás
actualmente buscando alguno entonces no
tendría por qué ser contemplado dentro
de la fuerza de trabajo entonces puedes
estar de preguntando qué significa estar
activamente en búsqueda de trabajo a lo
que voy con esto es que llevas cuatro
semanas o estas últimas cuatro semanas
has estado en búsqueda de algún nuevo
empleo y no has logrado conseguirlo
entonces en las últimas cuatro semanas
has estado buscando empleo y no lo has
conseguido y vas a decir cómo podemos
saber que estos 15 millones de personas
han estado buscando trabajo estas
últimas cuatro semanas y lo que pasa es
que cada humano por sobrevivencia en la
fuerza de trabajo para la población de
los eeuu son todos los 15 millones de
desempleados que deberían estar
logísticamente trabajando y puede ser
imposible que no tengan cómo sobrevivir
y en este
momento ellos hacen aproximadamente 60
mil personas cada mes y prácticamente
les preguntan o les discuten la
importancia de por qué ellos quieren
conseguir empleo o porque han estado
buscando empleo por las últimas 4
semanas
entonces si tú has estado buscando
durante las últimas cuatro semanas
empleo a ti se te deberá de considerar
parte dentro del bloque de las personas
que están en dicha necesidad y aún no lo
consigue entonces tú si serias parte de
la fuerza de trabajo pero esto no
debería desalentar a la población porque
es poco probable que pasen más tiempo
del que ya han pasado sin trabajo pues
tal vez se den por vencidos pero más
adelante si haya una oportunidad de
quedarse en algún trabajo del que se
había estado buscando en los últimos
cuatro semanas por alguien que ha sido
arrojado fuera de la fuerza laboral o
por quien puedes tú sustituir y aquí es
donde creo que la gente es donde ya no
alcanza a realizar sus objetivos pues si
estas cosas siguen bastante mal entre la
población desanimada del desempleo
harían que esas salían de la fuerza
laboral lo que afectaría en gran rasgo
los números
finalmente digamos que a ésta
y la recesión o depresión haría que esos
15 millones de personas que llevan
cuatro semanas buscando empleo no
busquen más por lo que esto generaría
que cinco millones de personas salían de
la fuerza de empleo y los tuviéramos que
meter al subconjunto de la gente que no
laboran y quiere elaborar si haces esto
lo que pasaría es que ahora la cara del
desempleo luciría con 10 millones de
personas entonces esto será la fuerza de
trabajo y en el círculo verde ahora aquí
tendríamos 149 millones de personas
entonces ahora toda la fuerza de trabajo
de 149 millones de personas tiene un
nuevo porcentaje por aquellos que se
desaniman meses a lyon de la fuerza de
trabajo entonces lo que haríamos ahora
es obtener nuevo porcentaje de la tasa
de desempleo de los 10 millones
divididos entre 149 millones de personas
que nos vendrá arrojando aproximadamente
un 6.7 por ciento lo que esto significa
es que las cosas van un poco mal pues la
gente que dejó fuera la fuerza de
trabajo es por eso que la tasa de
desempleo obtuvo una pequeña baja pero
en realidad esto tiene un tipo de cambio
y me refiero a un cambio que quizás
puede que las cosas vayan bien
pero todo depende del tipo de población
y cómo se está distribuyendo pero podéis
imaginar que quizás en términos
económicos es bueno entre comillas
puesto que el espacio de trabajo
comenzaría a encontrar un buen punto
para su economía y quizás toda esta
gente desempleada ahora que no sería
tomada como parte de la fuerza de
trabajo entonces empezarán a buscar
quizás otras oportunidades de empleo
pero sin ser contemplados como dentro de
la población económicamente activa
entonces luego ellos con esto serán
oficialmente parte de la tasa del
desempleo de los 10 millones que ahora
tendrían una alza de 10 millones más
entonces estos serán ahora 159 millones
en esta situación entonces esta cifra
ahora sería de 159 millones de personas
que conformarían la fuerza oficial de
trabajo y el desempleo sería de 20
millones de personas entonces si
queremos hacer esta división oeste
consciente de los 159 personas que ahora
forman la fuerza con los 20 millones de
desempleo aproximadamente nos arrojaría
un 12.6 por ciento entonces este
cociente que nos arroja el 12.6 por
ciento así que
veamos cómo va variando la población y
cómo va variando la tasa de desempleo
dependiendo cómo se esté comportando así
que finalmente lo interesante o el
meollo de este vídeo no quiere decir que
la tasa del desempleo sea la forma para
catalogar exactamente a la población
sino simplemente está dándonos una
imagen o un panorama de lo que en
realidad es el complemento porque en
particular este único número justo es un
porcentaje que no nos habla más allá de
lo que representa cada personaje en la
población económicamente activa sino
simplemente esto nos está dando como lo
que típicamente nos presentan en la
televisión de las noticias cuando hablan
de una tasa de desempleo porque dicho
porcentaje no nos está dando las causas
o está penetrando realmente en el por
qué está dicha tasa está en constante
movimiento con el desempleo ni tampoco
nos presenta la gente que quizás se va
uniendo las fuerzas de trabajo y
presente una peor situación de lo que en
realidad es